challenge for habilitation the child
with the congenital rubella syndrome a
maternal viral infection during
pregnancy especially in the first three
months has the potential for producing a
number of harmful effects in the
developing fetus an estimated twenty to
thirty thousand children were born with
the congenital rubella syndrome as the
result of the 1964-65 rubella epidemic
in the United States this group of one
and a half to four year old children in
the clinic reception area are all in the
rubella program at the Texas Children's
Hospital in Houston when the 146
patients were reviewed in 1967 ninety
had hearing loss 39 were visually
impaired and 50 had significant motor
handicap of these there were twenty
deafblind with impairment of both
hearing and vision the use of more
definitive diagnostic studies and
clinical observation showed that the 17
considered normal probably did not have
the congenital rubella syndrome
comprehensive evaluations were done on
80 children at age two and a half years
in order to project their educational
needs those with primarily an auditory
or visual handicap were eligible for
existing preschool programs the staff of
the child development clinic initiated a
diagnostic therapeutic nursery for the
25 multiply handicapped children their
arbitrary classification as mild
moderate or severe was based on physical
developmental and behavioral deviations
the clinic offers interdisciplinary
services for the parents and child
individual sessions with the social
worker focus on current stresses
produced by the presence of a
handicapped child in the family the
persistence of rubella virus may cause
progression of known
physical abnormalities and development
of new ones
the pediatrician must therefore evaluate
all systems in his periodic examination
during each regular I examine ation the
ophthalmologist looks for evidence of
congenital cataract glaucoma microbe
falmouth and rubella retinopathy similar
in-depth studies are done by the
cardiologist otologist audiologist and
orthopedist maturation cognition and
behavior while related to the degree of
structural abnormality cannot be defined
by physical examination alone
developmental and psychological profiles
are used by the psychologist to
determine the mental age and to identify
specific areas of functional delay or
deficit the psychologists have selected
different test instruments for three
children of comparable chronological age
based on prior knowledge of their
medical disability and direct
observation of their behavior
excitability and inattention rather than
the severity of visual and hearing
impairment prevent this deafblind girl
from performing on the ghazal
developmental tests the hearing impaired
but otherwise normal child is being
tested with the non verbal Leiter
international scale her intellectual
potential as well as effect on behavior
are appropriate
performance on the stanford-binet
indicates that this physically normal
boy is also of average intelligence at
five years of age however immunological
tests showed that his original diagnosis
of rubella was probably incorrect motor
skills particularly creeping crawling
and walking did not develop in an
orderly progression for most of the
congenital rubella patients for some
children athetosis spasticity or
hypotonia resulting from central nervous
system involvement was a significant
handicap this girl with [ __ ] diplegia
in addition to correctable auditory and
visual impairment has had individual
physical therapy and has been fitted
with long leg braces and crutches
overcoming architectural barriers such
as stairs at school is a part of her
gait training the earlier motor handicap
of the boy at the table is not evident
since he no longer needs a short leg
brace both of these children have
progressed from the multi handicap
program to a preschool deaf class their
functional vision and auditory
amplification allow them to interact and
to respond with pleasure to the sight
and sound of the barking toy dog
an area of baldness is seen on the back
of the heads of many rubella children
this resulted from the type of bizarre
movement and self-stimulatory activity
demonstrated by this 18 month old
deafblind motor delayed child the multi
handicapped girl in the parallel bars
has only minimal muscle weakness and is
at a readiness stage for walking her
distractibility short attention span and
her poor vision even with contact lenses
are preventing her independent
locomotion
she later progressed to walking alone
with one hand on the wall but would not
cross an open doorway until provided
with a yardstick with which to maintain
contact with the floor or wall hypotonia
and muscle weakness although initially
present in many of the children usually
improved by the age of two and a half
years this severely hypotonic boy is
still unable to hold his head erect at
age four years the physical therapist is
positioning him so as to utilize his
minimal muscle power to help develop
motor function
the therapist attempts to stimulate head
control by holding his attention with a
flashlight and a spinning musical top
head control would have to be
established in the normal neuro
developmental sequence before he could
coordinate movements of his arms legs
and trunk his inability to maintain a
given posture is fatiguing and soon
results in loss of motivation
although this little girl has normal
vision and aided hearing within the
speech range coordinated upper extremity
movement is extremely difficult for her
due to severe spasticity and athetosis
the occupational therapist is
demonstrating inactivity which requires
the child to use the fine muscles of her
hand and forearms for grasping and the
gross muscles of her shoulders and arms
for reaching and placing the block on
the pedestal this demands a great effort
from the child who is rewarded by an
approving facial expression and verbal
praise from the therapist psychomotor
retardation and maladaptive behavior
prevent establishment of the oral
mechanisms of sucking chewing and
swallowing the essential antecedents of
eating and drinking the occupational
therapist is attempting to teach this
three and a half year old boy each step
in the hand-to-mouth progression of self
feeding first he must learn to grasp the
spoon or cup hold on to it and then move
it through space from the table to his
mouth with increasing dexterity and
minimal spilling he rejects not only the
utensils but any interaction with the
therapist herself even in children who
are attentive upper extremity weakness
lack of motor control and poor eye hand
coordination may delay the acquisition
of self-help skills the speech therapist
must consider both mental and
chronological age in programming for
multiply handicapped children she
teaches the mothers of children under
three years of age how to provide
language stimulation through daily
activities a bell is used by this mother
to make her 18 month old girl aware of
environmental sounds such awareness is a
forerunner to comprehension of the
spoken voice this three-year-old boy
prefers to
through the hole in the plastic ring
rather than use the ring appropriately
when his mother has his attention he can
comprehend her directions a standing
board is used for positioning and total
body support of the hypotonic boy shown
previously on the mat this allows him to
participate in a small group conducted
by the speech therapist he responds
appropriately by laughing at the barking
dog and attempts to use his arms and
hands to grasp the coloured rings on the
other hand the deafblind girl shows no
more interest in auditory stimulation
than she did an independent locomotion
the nursery groupings for peer
interaction are based on the degree of
impairment and the cumulative effect of
multiple handicaps on behavior those
classified as severe are immature and
have inappropriate emotional responses
lack of environmental awareness and self
stimulation which prevent optimal group
participation many of these deafblind
children are absorbed in stereotyped
activities frequently referred to as
blind isms waving their hand in front of
their eyes seems to produce a hypnotic
flicker effect jabbing the thumb or
forefinger into the globe of the eye
appears to be pleasurable rather than
painful for them the therapeutic program
is designed to develop the child's
attention span his awareness of others
and his own self-concept this
goal-directed activity is most difficult
to achieve with these autistic like
children who do not interact with the
group for this reason one-to-one
behavior modification techniques are a
more successful training method children
in the moderate group function at about
the one-year language level by gazelle
developmental norms although they are
able to understand and execute a verbal
command their attention span is short
distraction by pleasurable visual
stimulation often prevents completion of
the task to
and by the therapists sighting through
the translucent cup into a direct light
results in amplification of the child's
existing nystagmus and represents
another example of a pleasurable blind
ism the children in the mild multi
handicap group are able to comprehend
directions and carry out a fine motor
activity emphasizing color matching and
number concepts this represents a level
of function which approaches their
chronological age they have a longer
attention span and watch and interact
with the other children most have a
moderate to severe neurosensory hearing
loss but have adequate vision to lip
read and make maximal use of visual
clues given by the teacher imagery play
is used by the nursery teacher to
initiate group interaction with three
children they are over three and a half
years of age but are still at the
parallel play stage of social
development the little boy was placed in
the nursery program for habilitation of
multiple handicaps resulting from head
injury although his physical appearance
and combination of handicaps is somewhat
different from the children with
congenital rubella the therapeutic
approach is essentially the same over
the past three and a half years the
parents and professional staff have
mutually benefited from the discussion
and educational groups focused on the
management of these handicapped children
the nursery teacher is demonstrating how
to make an edible play dough from flour
water and food coloring the speech
therapist then shows the parents how
they may use the playdough for language
stimulation by the use of simple phrases
such as take it roll it and pull it
which are clearly enunciated so that the
child can read their lips
continuous monitoring and discussion of
each child's progress at
interdisciplinary Staffing's provides
the basis for projecting short and long
term functional and educational goals
for optimal habilitation